121番ですが チューラスンニャタースッタンというところで
それで始まります エワンメーソタンエカンサマヤンバガワーサーワッティヤンヴィーラティプッバーラーミーミガーラマートゥパーサーデー
この経典はお釈迦様がこのプッバーラムという東インドとかね
今 プッバーラマという商社ですね
で ミガーラマートゥという女性の信者さんが作ったお寺で
そちらに住んでいた時の経典です
アテ
コアーヤスマーナンドーサーヤンナサマヤンパティサッラーナウッティトーイェーナバガワーテーヌパサンカメーパサンカミットゥワーバガワンタンアビワディットゥワーエーカマンタンニシーディー
その時アナンダソンジャが
午後 パティサッラーナウッティトーっていうのは
一人でどこかに いわゆる午後瞑想したりしますからね
昼食終わってからね それで午後になってから
またお釈迦様のところに大体みんな集まります
その時 お釈迦様のところに行ってお釈迦様に礼をしますと
エーカマンタンニシンノーコーアヤスマーナンドーバガワンタンエータダオーチェ
それで傍らのスワタナンダソンジャがお釈迦様にこのようなことを言いました
エーカミダハン・バンテ・サマヤン・バガワー・サッケーサ・ヴィーラティ・ナガラカン・ナーマ・サッキャーナン・ニガモ
タッタメー・バンテ・バガワトー・サッムカー・スタン・サッムカー・パティッガヒータン・スンニャター・ヴィハーレーナ・アハン・アーナンダ
エータラヒ・バフラン・ヴィーラーミ・カッチミタン・マン・カッチメタン・バンテ・スッスタン・スッガヒータン・スマナシカタン・スーパダーリタンティ
そこでこのアナンダソンジャがこのようなことをお釈迦様に聞くんですね
エーカミダハン・バンテ・ソンジ
ある日 エーカミダハンというのもある日ですね
ある時 サメアンというのはまた時のことで
ある日 ある時 バガワー・サッケーサ・ヴィーラティ
ソンジがサッカという町に
いわゆる釈族の国ですよ
その国で住んでいた時
その場所はナガラカン・ナーマ・サッキャーナ・ニガモ
ナガラカというニガマですね
村よりは大きい 町よりは小さいというかね
かなりいわゆる地方ですね
ナガラカという地方に住んでいましたと
タッタメー・バンテ・バガワトー・サッムカー・スタン・サッムカー・パティッガヒータン
その時 私はお釈迦様からサッムカー・スタン
お釈迦様から直々聞きました
サッムカー・パティッガヒータン
お釈迦様から直々それを受け取りまして
理解して了解しましたと
何でしたっけ？というと次に来るんですね
それは スンニャター・ヴィハーレーナ・アハン・アーナンダ・エータラヒ・バフラン・ヴィーラーミ
アーナンダ アーナンダよ
エータラヒ 今頃 この頃
スンニャター・ヴィハーレーナ
スンニャターという生き方
いわゆる空ですね そういう生き方で
この頃もうそっちゅうスンニャターという感覚というかね
空 空照と書いてますけどね
空照の住まいによって
何度も住んでいます というかね
まあそっちゅうということで
何回何回も いわゆるそっちゅう
スンニャター・ヴィハーラという空照というね
そういうヴィハーラっていうのは生き方ということで住んでいるということではないんです
まあまあ それ日本語でどんな意味かわかりませんだけど
この空照に住まいによって空照の住まいというふうに日本訳になってますけどね
まあヴィハーラっていうのは生きているんだということで
空照というものを実践しながらいましたよと
もうそっちゅう空照ということを実践していたんだよという意味なんです
そこでカッチメタン・バンテ・スッスタン
いかがでしょうか ソンジ
それは私は正しく聞いてますかと
スッガヒータン 正しく覚えているんでしょうかと
スッガヒタンというのは受け取る
正しく受け取ってますか？スッスタン
正しく聞きましたか？正しくことりましたかと
ス・マナシカタン 正しくそのまま思い出してますかと
スッパダーリタン それは記憶のこと
正しく覚えておいておきますか？まあそういう言葉 4つぐらい出てくるんですけど
意味は私はそれ合ってますか？っていうぐらいの意味なんですね
であの注釈書によると
まあアナンダ尊者がこの食事後
涅槃という解脱というものを対象にして瞑想に入っていて
まあそれでまあそれについてお釈迦様から何か聞きたいと
といっても 自分が直接
まあスンヤタ空性って何なのかと何とか聞けちゃうと
まあそれはまあお釈迦様が教えてくれるかどうかちょっとわからないと
なんかいきなり言って私にこういうことを教えてくださいということは
まあ私にとってはできませんと聞くことはね
ですから このまあそうやってお釈迦様の何か話を出して
お釈迦様こういうことを教えますたけど
それはえいがものなんでしょうかと言えば
お釈迦様はそれを自分がおっしゃったことを説明するだろうというふうな
まああまりにもこのもう回り道なんですね
で まあそれは注釈書の説明というかね
まあ問題は本当にアナンダ尊者に
まあスンヤタ・ヴィハーラという空性の禅定できますかということもありますけど
うん それはちょっとわかりません
アナンダ尊者がお釈迦様亡くなってから悟り開いたという話でしょうし
で まあソーターパットで預流果というところまでは悟りは開いていましたけど
まあ大体預流果になっただけでは
このスンヤタ空性禅定に入るということはね
まあそう簡単にできるものではありません
不還果ぐらいになってないと
あるいは禅定に達せてないと
禅定に達してると預流果になった人にもできますけど
悟ってないと全く無理です
まあ空性禅定っていうのは
うん だからまあちょっとわかりません
とにかくこういう で お釈迦様の答え
タッガ テータン アナンダ スッス タン スッガ ヒタン スマニ シカ タン スーパダーリタン
タッガ 確かにこのその通りだと
あなたはよく覚えてますか
その通りに プッベチャーハン アナンダ エータラ ヒチョ スンニャタ・ヴィハーレナ バフラン・ヴィハラーミ
プッベチャ 前も それからエータラ
今も私がスンヤタ・ヴィハーラという空性禅定を実践しながら
まあ実践ではなくて その禅定
で まあその実践しながらまあ生きてるんだと
生活してる それでいきなり例えが入ってきて
セイヤターピアヤンニガーラマートゥパーサードースンヨハッティガワーサワラウェーヌスンヨジャットゥーパラジャテーナスンヨイッティプーリササンニパーテーナア
ッティチェーウィダンスンヤアスンヤタンヤディダンビッキュサンガンパティッチヤエーカッタングエーワメーワコーアーナンダビッキュアマナシカリットゥワーガー
マサンニャンアマナシカリットゥーマヌッササンニャンアラニャサンニャンパティッチヤマナシカロティーエーカッタング
そこでこの禅定のやり方をお釈迦様は説明していくんですね
例えばセイヤターピアヤンニガーラマートゥパーサードー
例えばこのニガーラマートゥパーサーダっていうのはもうビルということなんですね
もうニガーラマートゥビルっていうビルディングですよ
まあパーサーダっていうのは大体人が住んでるものだから
日本語の言葉で言えばマンションですよ
で 英語ではマンションとは言わないですけど
で いわゆる大きな建物でしたしね
で このニガーラマートゥっていう
この建物にしてみれば
スンニョハッティガワアッサワラウェーナ
このもう建物と まあまあまだ土地とかにありますけど
スンニャ空っぽですと
なんでハッティゾウはいません
とかね ゾウのことを考えると
もうガワっていうのはウシ
アッサっていうのはウマ
ワラワっていうのはおそらくロバでしょう
まあとにかくこのまあ
このニガーラマートゥという
このお寺とその土地の方で
まあ馬も牛もゾウも まあそういう動物はいないと
その点ででは その点で空ですよと
空っぽですよと それからスンニョトゥジャートゥーパラジャテーナ
これはあの まあかなりの大きな
あの殿堂でしたか 日本訳はね
まあ殿堂ですけど 別に金銀宝石などはあるわけでもないんですと
それからスンニョイッティプーリササンニパーテーナ
それからその中にあの男
人々もね 男たち女たちの集まりも全くないと
そういう点で見ると まあスンニャであると
空であると 空っぽであると
アッティチェーワイダンアスンニャタン
でもある側面でアスンニャ
も空というかね まあ空でない場合もありますと
空っぽではない アスンニャっていうのはスンニャの反対語
だからまあ非空性というかね
まあ空性というか まあ無空性でも呼んでですけどもあります
それはどういう点でいけば
ビッキュサンガンパティッチヤ
まあ比丘たちがいるんだと
だから比丘たちのことを考えると空ではありません
でもゾウやら馬やら金銀宝石のことを考えちゃうと
人々のことを考えちゃうと
これはまあ空ですと ですから
こちらでこの何を考えているんでしょうかというね
何を測ではないんですね
立場とかね 基準にしているかというね
その基準によって空にもなるし
空でなくなったりもしますということなんですね
まあ例えから見ればね
まあゾウがいますか？で言えばいませんということになりますね
馬がいますかという だから馬を見たいという角度で観察すると
空という答えが出てくる
ゾウがいるかという角度でゾウを探す
その角度で見ると空という答えが返ってくる
で でも違う角度で まあじゃあ人々がいるんでしょうか
今また空いませんとという空性という答えが返ってくる
でもあの比丘サンガはいかがでしょうか
やっぱり比丘サンガはいますから
そこで空性っていうことは成り立たないんですね
いるんだから だから有と無みたいな感じ
でもまあまあまあ言葉のことですからね
だからどのような返事が来るかと
ある立場で見ると無という答えが出てきて
ある立場で見ると有という答えは答えが出て返ってくるということ
エー
ワメーワコーアーナンダビッキュアマナシカリットゥワーガーマサンニャンアマナシカリットゥーマヌッササンニャンアラニャサンニャンパティッチヤマナシカロティーエーカッタング
そこでまあすごいこのまあ簡単な説明で
そのように人がアマナシカリットゥワーガーマサンニャン
村というこのサンニャン
概念ですよ サンニャンっていうのはね
村というサンニャー概念でもあって現象でもあります
だから我々は現象を認識しているんですね
ありのまま認識するということはしません
で 頭の中で現象を作って
それを認識する ですから
それは普通の認識の方で
だから外を見ると 何を見るかと
木を見るか森を見るかという問題でね
で いっぱい木がある時はね
まああんた何を見る？ある人は木を木を見ますよと言うかもしれません
ある人は森ですよと言うかもしれませんね
だから実際森ですか 木ですかと
それはもうその人の頭でどんな現象を作っているかということのことであって
別にそれだけのことなんですね
まあ一応それ以上簡単な例えがないし
この森と木という例えっていうのは普通
あの哲学やらね 論述とよく使う例えでしょうしね
フォレストとTREETREESというね Whatdo
you see？一人がフォレスト森を
これが森ですと言うかもしれません
他の人はTREES木ですよとというかもしれませんね
日本で木の複数形は何でしたっけね
木々  木々 木々ですよと
森ですか？木々ですかと
それはその見ている人はどういう現象を頭の中で作るかということであって
だから現象っていうのは
まあ一応サンニャー 日本訳ではそうとなってると思いますけど
まあ私が一生懸命この現象という言葉に引っかかって説明しているんだから
それはこの伝統的な仏教用語と違って
もっと現代的な用語ではないかなと思います
だから色受想行で言ってもなかなか大変ですよ
その理解は そういうことで
その現象という言葉を使ってますけど
サンニャーっていうのは現象ということなんですね
そこである人はガーマ・サンニャンという村という世界のことなんですね
世界 自分が生きている世界に対して
村やら町やら そういう国やらね
そういういろいろ我々思考というか概念というか現象というものは自分で認識しているんですね
それは認識しないで アマニスカリットワ
それは観察しないで それからアマニスカリットワ
マヌッササンニャ 人間という概念現象も観察しないことにする
アランニャサンニャン
アランニャ っていうのは
まあもう何もないところって意味だと思いますけど
これ日本訳ではどう 森の相になってますけどね
この下 この番号振ってるところは
この注釈書にある意味の定義
解釈ですけどね そう とにかく森という
まあアラニャっていうのはね
なんかこの空き地っていうぐらいの感覚で取ってるところなんですね
この美しい森とかね そういう感じじゃないんです
だからブッダゴーシャの注釈で言ってるようでもないと思いますけど
で 普通のパーリ語だったらね
まあ例えばまあ自然のことを考えてね
まあそういう自然の まあ森とかね
まあ言うと もう自然のところでも山があって
川があって いろいろ動物がいて
まあそれはフォレストではないかなと
で まあそればというよりは
このアラニャっていうのは空き地という風な
このもう何もない いわゆるあってほしいものっていうのはあってほしいではなくてね
普通あるものは何もないところという感じなんですよ
そこを先生はアラニャさんと
ん？ 何もあってほしくないという
欲しくないではなくて
ある 普段あるものはないところ
空き地って言えばその意味でしょう
これは空き地だと ということは
建物もないし 店もないし
水道もないしね 電気もついてないし
で 例えば日本庭園だったら空き地と言わないでしょ
人が住んでいなくても
まあこちらにある代々木公園もね
まあ実際空地ですけどね
空き地と言わないんですよ
空き地という あの概念は生まれてこないんです
じゃあ空き地というのは誰が住んでますかと
誰も住んでません 住んでませんだけど
空き地ではありません
空き地といえば ちょっと感覚が違う
もうパーリ語のアランヤっていうのは空き地という意味なんですよ
で 普通は まあアラニャという森なんですけど
辞書の意味はね で これ修行に取る場合はもうちょっと感覚的に意味を取ってみるんですね
で まあそこら辺 ブッダゴーシャの解釈はもう全くないんですよ
だからこの初期仏教の
お釈迦様の時代の そのお坊さんたちが
お釈迦様が考えた感覚を説明しなくちゃいけないんです
だから空き地という概念で
空き地という現象で そこは頭に観察するんだと入れて
そこでどういうことかというと
あ ここら辺は全部空き地やと思うと
あの今まであったあらゆる現象
概念から心が離れていくんですね
例えば商店街にいて さっと何か乗り物に乗って
さっとかなり離れたところで
もう何も建物何もない
もうかなり広大な空き地のところに行ってしまったら
もう空き地だなということを心に入れちゃうと
あの商店街という現象が消えて
概念が消えてしまうんですね
その心の働きをこちら説明しているんですね
どういうふうになるかというと
自分が商店街にあったアパートに住んでいたならば
うるさくてうるさくて
もう人々がいつでも出入り
出入り 出入りばっかりしていて
車が入るわとかね 昼間は人ばっかりで
夜になってきたらトラックが来て荷物を運送したりとかね
また喋ったり またもうなんか長くて
もうもう大変ですね で
それで大変疲れたりもしますね
それで一番忙しくて一番騒ぎがある時は
その人 さっと空き地 空き地の方に行ってしまえば
あ 空き地だなと思った瞬間
今までやった頭の中でガチャガチャと回転していたあのいろんな思考概念というのは全てさっと消えてしまって
落ち着きが出てくるんですね
で ものすごく疲れが その疲れが全部消えてしまうんですね
その働きですね こちら説明しているのは
で なかなか注釈書役に立たないんですね
この説明では タッサ アランニャ サンニャーヤ チッタン パッカンダティ パシーダティ サンティッタティ ビムッチャティ
そこで空き地だ 空き地だということを観察すると
それその人の心がその空き地について定着してしまうんですね
そちらに集中してしまう
他のこと知らない状態になってしまう
心に空き地という現象がもう入ってしまって
空き地という概念が入ってしまって
それからの思考の回転は空き地という土台というかね
その尺度じゃないんですね
そのビューポイントというかね
あの見方で全部自分の思考がもうまたもう作り直すんですね
まあそれはすごい簡単なことで
すぐ瞬時にできることで
あの そのその我々でも行く行く場所によって思考パターン
すぐこう あの再構成するでしょ
こちらにいると まあこちらの概念現象で
まあ自分の生き方 喋り方
もう全部再構成します
思考概念 じゃあ人格が変わるんですよ
それでどこかへ外へ行ったら
その行った場所において
マクドナルドに行ったら
それに合わせて全ての思考概念
生き方 人格が変わる マクドナルドではなくて高級レストランに入ってしまえば
またそちらにある概念で
あの思考パターンと人格も全て構成して変わってしまいますね
だから人の人格というのはそういう風にもう変わるもんなんです
だから 例えば銭湯に入ったら
銭湯にいるような気持ちで高級レストランにいるっていうことは全くありえないんですね
だから一旦銭湯に入ったら
そのその自分いるいるいるいるいる場所によって概念が変わって
思考パターンが変わって
人格まで変わるんです
で そこから銭湯から出て行って
また家に入って またいろいろ服を着て
またそのまま まあかなり高級なレストランに食事に行ったとしますね
そうすると またもう別な人間なんですよ
そういう風にこの心っていうのは
この観察するものにおいて
このこのあらゆる概念をね
まあ組み立てて新しい人格というものを作るという機能があるんですよ
明確に それはもう誰にでも簡単にもう経験
経験はしてますけど 理解できるものだと思いますね
そこでこの空き地という
森という もう何もない
建物もない もうもう人々もいませんと
いませんとね まあ現代風に言えば電気もないし
水道もないんだと もう建物もないんだと
コンビニもないんだと
で 誰かね もうしっかりと考えて作った庭園とかね
そんなものも何もないんだと
単なる空き地だ  [笑い]という概念に定着してしまう
そうなると そうなるとどうなりますかと
その人のそのその間の人格はね
そうエヴァンパジャナアディ
その人はこのようなことを知りますよと
ジェアッスダラタガマサンニャンパティッチャーテダナサンティ
ジェアッスダラタ 何か疲れが
ダラタっていうのは疲れであって
これストレスのことなんです
で ガマサンニャンパティッチャー
村 村と言ったっても この部落と人々の人々住んでいる場所ですね
町と言った方がもっといいんですけどね
町という概念で ガマと言えばね
もうたくさん人々がいる
家はいっぱいあるわ 牛がいるわ
もう馬がいるわ もうもう商売
商店街あるとかね 酒飲み場所があるとかね
賭け事をするところがあるとかね
そういういっぱい昔風に言えばありましたし
今風に言えばね パチンコやパチンコ店があって
またもう八百屋さんがいて
また普通のね もう店いっぱいあったりとかね
で まだそこら辺にまだ学校もあって
また遊園地もちょっとしたものがたりもういろいろあることでしょうし
だから車は行ったり来たりとか
そうやってもう複雑な場所ですね
その場所で その人格でいる時は
自分にいろんな複雑なもの心に入りますから
かなりいろいろ心はもう動揺したりしますね
見たくないものを見えちゃうと嫌な気持ちになっちゃうし
もう見たいものを見てしまっちゃうとすごい機嫌が良くなったりもするし
で 買い物に行こうではないかなと行って
店に喜んで行っちゃうと会いたくない人に会ったりするし
だから自分が会いたくない口聞けない人も一緒に同じ店で買い物しているとかね
見ちゃうとまた心がいろいろ変化するしというふうないろんなもの
出来事が出てくるんですね
こちら黙ってもう店に行きたいんだけど
誰かがもうそこら中に住んでる
誰が向こう側向こう側から来ると来ると
やっぱり挨拶しなくちゃいけないということになっちゃうしね
そうやってこのガマに村にいると
そういう激しい心の変動というかね
変化っていうのは必ずしも起こりますし
その概念の中で生きなくちゃいかないし
で そういう場合はもういろんなストレスというものはね
疲れが心にもう溜まって溜まって溜まっていくんです
だから見たいものを見る時でもストレス溜まるんですよ
面白い 面白いとかね 見ていると結局は疲れてしまいます
だから面白くないものを見ても疲れてしまう
面白いものを見ても疲れてしまう
そうやってこの疲れ 疲れたというものがね
どんどん心に溜まっていく
そこでその村 町という概念から自分に生まれてきたこの疲れが
ストレスが全部消えていくんだよね
って いでな ナサンティ
で 今空き地という概念で
その世界に入り込んじゃって
もう生きて生活しているんだから
あの疲れが全部今はない
町という疲れが アッティチャエーアヤムダラタマッタヤディダンアランニャサンニャンパティッチャーエカッタン
でもエカッタン一つの疲れがあります
エカッタンというのはワンタイプという種類の疲れがあります
それはどういう疲れが疲れかというと
空き地だと 空き地という思考で
概念でもう生活しなくちゃいけないんだからね
人格変わっちゃいますからね
でも村と比べてみると
もうかなり楽なんですよ
気持ちはものすごい楽
楽だけど 今はたった種類
一つの種類の疲れがあります
空き地という概念から出てくると
そう
スンニャンイダンサンニャガタンガマサンニャーイサンニャーヤティパジャナアティスンニャンイダンサンニャガタンマヌッササンニャーヤティパジャナアティアッティチェーヴァイダンスンニャ
ー スンニャタンヤディダンアランニャサンニャンパティッチャーエカッチャンティ
スンニャタン だからその修行者が
自分の心が 自分の思考が
自分の頭の中に入り込んでいるあらゆる概念の中で
もう人々という概念がもうないんだと
そんな考え方はまるっきり今ないんだと
それで楽になる だからこの概念が逃げて逃げていると
かなり楽になる ストレスが消えていくんだということなんです
概念だから現象という言葉が一番ぴったしなんですよ
村という現象が心から消えちゃったもん
それでその現象から生まれてきた村という現象からね
概念では現象ですよ 概念といえば
まあただ頭の概念ですから
村という現象からもう離れちゃったんだからね
もうかなり楽やと もう今自分の心に村という現象がありません
人々という現象はありませんと
街という現象もありませんと
そうやって複雑なこの現象が一つ一つ全部もうなくなって
スンニャスンニャ 空性というところになっているんだと
でも一つだけまだ残っていると
それはまあ空き地というのは
自分が今空き地のところで生活
住み着いて 空き地という現象に住み着いているんだと
これはあの まあまあね
みんなに当てはまる例え話はないんですけど
あの 結婚式なんかするとね
女の子たちがなんとか服着るでしょ
あれは白なんていうんですか
白無垢だったら白無垢
そういう服着ますね あれは西洋の服よりは落ち着いてますか
皆様にとっては西洋の服よりはもうすごい落ち着いてて派手ではありませんと
西洋のベールとかね それすごい派手やと思っているかもしれませんだけど
あれかなり派手なんですよ
かなり高価で で 西洋のウェディングドレスっていうのはほとんど裸ですからね
何かバカでかいネットを頭にかぶって
もうそれだけのことで
まあね 材料から見ればそんな大したもんじゃないんですよ
でも日本の白無垢っていうのは
もう材料でももうかなりの上等なものなんです
で だからまあベールはないだけでね
でも頭に何か角隠しというものを着けますけど
で でもまあまあベールというね
ではないんですね  綿帽子という白い帽子をかぶる
かぶるの  それが角隠しです
あれなんか布でできてるんじゃないの
そうです 布と同じ  で やっぱりその時でも
やっぱり着る着物も やっぱりそれでも下すごく長いんでしょうね
あの道路なんかに歩けませんね
公園なんかではね それでそうやってすごい豪華な美しい服なんか着ていると
その人はそれに合わせて思考パターン持たないと
大変ですね だから普段もうあっちこち走り回っていた女の子かもしれませんだけど
それ着ちゃうとそんな走り回りはできません
誰か後ろから服をね あの床にね
まあ触れないようにしてあげなくてはいけないし
移動 それで好き勝手にいろいろあっち向いたりこっち見たりとかね
下見たりとかね いろんなものを拾ったりとかね
そういうこともできません
あれ着たらもうきちんと背を伸ばして
もう言ってる通りにゆっくりと歩くしか方法ないんですね
歩いてもう決まってる所に何とか座ると
だからかなりこの生き方
何から何までもその白無垢という服を着たら管理されちゃいますよ
それで それで結婚式終わってからは一つ一つ抜くでしょうにね
それで普通の洋服に着替えたりすると
その場合はあの服がなくなっちゃったんだから
もう結構楽でしょ あのストレスが消えちゃいますよ
それでみんなお客様みんな帰ってから
あの服ももう捨ててしまって
普通に パンツとかなんとか履いたりしますね
その時はもっと楽になっちゃいますね
その人がまた寝ようとするね
そうするともう何かパジャマとかなんとか着たりしますね
その時はさらに楽になるんですね
そこでお釈迦様 そのどのように楽になるか
ストレスが消えるかと
すごいストレス消えますよ
例えばパジャマになったらもうほとんどストレスはないんです
一番リラックスできる服なんです
もうベースに何も見え
ものも何も要りませんだからね
もう家の中で もう布団に入る
もうすぐパジャマに入れ替えるんだから
もう何も見えも何も要りませんね
それでもう外へちょっと行って
もうもうもう何て言いますか
この何かの販売機で何かジュースでも買おうとそこまででも大体しないんだからね
だからもうお風呂から上がってパジャマに着替えて
そのままそっとまあお布団に行くだけだから
まあ大体はもうかなりリラックスない状態なんですね
このリラックスのない
間違った このすごいリラックスの状態
あのストレスのない状態
これはどちらから生まれてきたかと
それはお釈迦様がこれはシュンヤターから生まれてくるものだよと
空想という概念から生まれてくるものだよと
もしその時でも空想という概念なくなっちゃうと
またストレスが溜まる
このパジャマはなんとかどこかで買ったものやとかね
これは絹ですよとかね
そこでパジャマに合わせて歩いたり
ちょっと水でも飲みたくなったら
もうパジャマのこの縫製によって歩き方やらまた決めなくちゃいけないんですね
いくらなんでも それ面倒くさいからパジャマこうやってあげて
もう行くわけにもいきませんしね
ですから その分考えちゃうと
この空想じゃないというところから考えちゃうと
またストレスがあるんです
だから心のストレス 心の疲れっていうのは
どこで生まれてどこで消えるかという
この厳密なこの心理学的というかね
その機をお釈迦様は説明しようとしているところなんです
だからなかなか注釈書ではそういうもう思考は当時でなかったしね
で まあ助けにはなりませんですけど
そういうことをちゃんと説明している
そこを知らないと別に大した教典ではないではないかというふうに錯覚するかもしれません
でも大した教典ですよ
だからすごいちょっとしたことをこちら
あなたはあなたの現象ですか
概念 どこら辺に集中しているかと
あるということに集中しちゃう
しちゃうと疲れる ストレスが溜まる
なくなったと もうないと
それを思うとえらい気持ちいい
ですから 白無垢姿でいた女の子が３時間撮ったところでもうパジャマにいる
そこであれがなくなったと
もう終わったと思っちゃうと
えらいほっとしますね
だから空想っていうのは
そういう風にこの心を穏やかにしてくれる
リラックスしてくれる
あの疲れが ストレスが消してくれる概念なんですね
そういう訓練方法なんですね
ストレスを消すためには
だから人の見方次第 その女の子があっ
これからもうかっこよくこのパジャマに合うように美しく身振りというかね
もうしなくちゃいけないんだなと思っちゃうと
また新しいストレスが生まれてくるんですね
この自分が着たパジャマに合わせてもう可愛くぶっちゃうと
そうするとまた有というね
アシュンニャという現象でしょ
空ではないというね これからこの縁起だよっていうことになっちゃうとまた大変
ですから この疲れが消えるのは空性観察するときなんですね
ですから 空といって このもう大乗仏教でいうこの形而上学空はでは
誰かが悟ったと話も聞いてはありませんだけど
そういう形而上学的なことを言ってるわけじゃなくて
このすごい具体的に心はどうすれば穏やかになるんでしょうかというところで
このシュンニャという言葉を使ってます
だからいつでも実践的で
もう厳密に形而上学的な思考っていうのはもう置いておくんですね
で あの形而上学の話になったのを思い出したんだから言うんですけど
この形而上学で言ったら
この大乗仏教も全部形而上学なんです
有住の空論 それからヴァースバンドラたちが作ったこの唯識理論とかね
ああいうものをすべて形而上学なんです
お釈迦様から見れば かえってそんなことを勉強すると疲れちゃう
疲れる 例えば徹底的に有住の空論なんか勉強しても
最終的にだから何よということになるんですよ
それで何か落ち着きましたかと
落ち着かないんですよ
だって何も実体ありません
何も存在しません もうだから何もない
もう全部空やって それただ頭の遊びで
そこを世界の人々とね
もうなんてぶつかってね
だから大体そんなややこしいことを考えない人は
あんたアホではないかとかね
例えばどこら辺の百姓さんやらね
もうジャガイモ作ってる人とね
こんな空論なんか喋っちゃうとね
それでいい加減にしてくれませんかと
忙しいやと 私はと 言うのはもう決まってます
言われるのは だから単なるこの知識遊びで知識をいじりたくて
何か哲学やらね まあそれは間違ってるかないかと話じゃないんですよ
もしかすると論理的に哲学的に有住の空論は正しいかもしれませんよ
でもだからといってそれはというわけじゃなくて
この心の穏やかさ 心の平安
ストレスをなくすことっていうことを実際に具体的なことを考えちゃうと
もう単なる形而上学で学なんですね
だからこのまあ 形而上学だからお釈迦様は否定しています
でもそれはお釈迦様は後でできたものだからね
まあそれは仏典では当然なことに否定してないんです
知らなかったんだから
そんなことはね そんな自分の弟子の中でそれほどアホが生まれると思わなかったんだからね
[笑い]だって仏教というのは実践論だから
実践を飛ばしちゃって考えるだけで十分だと
というもうアホが出るとお釈迦様さえも予測しなかったでしょうと思いますけどね
だってそんなガチャガチャ考える人っていうのは
お釈迦様生前もいくらでもいたんだから
だから徹底的に否定するんですよ
そう論やらね 論争やらね
それからいろんな意見のぶつかり合いとかね
そんなアホしかその網に引っかからないんだよと
スッタニパータの中でもすごく明確に
なんでこの宗教家までもうそんなに苦しんでるんでしょうかと
あんた方のこの概念やと
ということを言ってるんだからね
苦しみの原因はね そんなものを捨てなさいよと
すべての現象とか概念とかね
と言ってたんだからね
だから同じ問題はね 仏教の中で
それは随分後でね お釈迦様亡くなって六百年ぐらいも経った後で
もうちょっとかなね できた思考ですから
お釈迦様は知りません
そんなことはね だから空中の空論はお釈迦様は何て言いますか
否定してはないんではないかとかね
言ったってもね それはもう話にならないことで
否定も肯定ももう成り立たないんですからね
いわゆるこちらで私は理解してほしいところは
このスンヤターということは
一応大乗仏教では大変な言葉で
現代実際にある大乗仏教よりも
この初期大乗仏教の場合は
もうこれは土台なんですね
スンヤター 空性というものはね
その上で思想哲学体系ができてあって
それで後でわからないんだから
実際に実践している大乗仏教ではもうどれも捨てているんですね
わかってない ですからもうなんか拝むことで
もう経をあげることとか何とか
そういうぐらいでもう留まっているんですね
それでいろいろ修行もなさっているお坊さんたちは当然当たり前でいますけど
ではもう何か空性について何かやっていますか？というと
全然何もやってないんですね
だから理屈で攻撃するんだったら
僕らのは理屈で あんた方はもう空性というものは土台ではないかと
初期仏教と違って それ
その基本的な教えがどのように修行に関係ありますかと
例えば我々の場合は四聖諦でしょ
九十メソッドでしょ 初期仏教やらテーラワーダ仏教の場合は
だから九十メソッドって四つはもうそのまま実践ですからね
それなきに修行できませんよ
だからもう一体になってますね
実践と真理というのは
大乗の場合はどういうことかと
ちょっと経験ないんですからね
わかりませんですけどね
で 座禅ぐらいはちょっと知ってますけど
座禅の中でもどのようにこの空性という思考はね
使用するかっていうことね
わかりません そこで日蓮系だったらね
南無妙蓮華というこればっかり唱えてるでしょうね
それで空性ってどういう関係でしょうかと
それはわかりませんね
だから一応比較的な思考にはならないんですよ
そういうわけで 結構後でできたことで
で 論理的に呼吸するというのはいくらでもできますけどね
でもあまり時代違ってるものだからね
比較していいかという問題も出てきます
とにかく空性という言葉はパーリ語
パーリ経典にも別に珍しい言葉ではありません
いろんなところで出てきます
ではそれと 龍樹の空という哲学といえば
ブッダが哲学はもう思考の遊びですからね
故に苦しみだからね まだ故にもう輪廻ですからね
それはもう輪廻を脱出する教えですから
すべての概念をもうまとめて処分しちゃうんですね
ゴミとして で それであの私はこの説明するところはまたメーカーのお釈迦様は次に行ってますけど
で こちらのポイントは
で 穏やかで平安で もう完全にこのストレスというものはね
もう消しちゃっていられる方法なんですよ
いわゆる楽にいる方法なんですね
もう悟るとか何とかというよりもね
日常生活の中でも確実に心がもういろんな矢で刺されてますよ
もうただ生けている花見ても心が痛むんですよ
何派とすぐ思っちゃいますからね
切りいたら あれ誰が入れたものか
すぐ 聞きたくなっちゃいますからね
それぐらいでもみんな感じてないだけで心が痛むんですよ
矢に刺されてるんです
だから綺麗なものを見ると気持ちいいとかね
そんな鈍感な人の話で綺麗なもの見たって結構ストレス溜まる
綺麗でないもの見たってのはかなりストレスが溜まる
自分一人でいる部屋に誰かが人が入ったか
その瞬間から心がストレスですよ
その対象が心にぶつかってぶつかって
それに合わせて喋ったり行動したりしなくちゃいけないんですね
ゴキブリ一匹入ったっても
あの心の穏やかさっていうのも消えちゃうんですよ
すっごくストレス溜まってしまっちゃいます
だから このこの厳密にこのものすごい鋭敏というかね
心感じないと本当にこの苦しみを捨てるということはできないんですよ
もう派手に鈍感で で 言うと
もうどうにもならんですね
だから このものすごい知恵
知恵っていうのはそういうことだから
知恵ある人っていうのは
ものすごい微かなものにもすごい敏感なんです
で その敏感が故にこの微かな疲れも取れるんですよ
これで疲れると で もうこれは至る所にあるもので
もう例えばこの食パン
朝食べますね その普通の店で売ってる
このパスコとかなんとかとか言うけどね
150円の食パン買ってきて
それはトーストにして食べる時と
かなり高級レストランでレストランではなくて
このパン屋さんで 350円の食パンもあります
それで食べ それだけでも心のあれ変わりますよ
それだけでも まあ朝じゃあトースト食べましょうと
トースト食べますとしたものは
まあかなりの特別なパン屋さんで買ったもの
もう 350円のパンだったら
食パンだったら その時の気持ちと
もうただそちら辺に行っても
あのもう私の場合は酒を売ってる店なんで
そちらのパンも 3 4つぐらい置いてあるんですね
そちらから買いますけどね
で まあそこをそのパン食べる時の気持ちっていうのはね
それだけでも変わります
です  そういうことを選んで選んで買う人っていうのは
激しい概念で悩んでいる人々だから
これが体にいいとかね
それで大量に作る場合は
化学の農夫菜とかいろんなものを入れているんだから
これは体に健康に悪いとか
あらゆる概念で悩んでるんですね
ですから あのお店の人は
このドイツで 5年いていて
修行して帰った人ですよとかね
天然酵母しか使ってないんですよとかね
というふうな概念 実際はどうかわかりませんよ
だからこの生協で売ってる野菜なんかの様子は
笑っちゃったんだからね
そんなこの 何と言うんですか
栽培法には 有機栽培と
それは基準から見るとなかなか無理ですよ
そこら辺でどこにでも 100m でもどこにでも化学肥料を入れてはいけません
すごく間も置いておかないとね
それで何年間も土を寝かしておかないとね
そんな土地 日本にあるかというね
それまた正しく言えばあっちこっちあるでしょうし
みんな買う時はこのまあもう 10g の野菜食べたい場合は大体もう 200g 買うでしょうに
だからもう買うこともね
全部生ゴミ出さなきゃなんか機嫌が悪いみたい
今日朝私は生ゴミ出しちゃったんだけど
小さな袋でこうやって持って出しちゃったんだけど
一緒に他のとこに住んでる女の人2人が来て
こんな感じでもうみっつみっつ持ってます
来るんですね 生ゴミの袋は
助けてあげようかなと思ったぐらい重いというかね
別にまあまあ二人とか 3人ぐらい住んでるかもしれませんけど
それぐらい出ますからね
だから捨てるために買うとね
まあそれまあそういうことだから
たくさん買うんだから大量に作らなくちゃいけないんでしょうね
店の方も お客さんが来て野菜買おうと果物買おうとしたら
今日は売れ切れと言っちゃうとね
もう商売になりませんから
だから まあだから実際の状況は分かりませんだけど
でも買うお客さんが これは有機栽培のもう大変信頼できる野菜っていう風な
この概念で思考で買ったりしますよ
その分も心がかなり刺されてます
いろんな概念の思考の矢で痛めています
だから このものすごい敏感に鋭く物事を見るということは
この心を安らかにしたい人にとっては一応必要なんですよ
まあ鈍感な方が楽やという風に言ってる人々いますけど
あまり気にしないと でもそれで楽っていうことでもないんですよ
まあ鈍感な人々もいろんな概念に悩んでいるんだからね
だからこの鈍感ということは決していいことじゃないんで
例えば自分の体にがんがあるんだよと
もう気にしないんだと言っても
がんだからそれは成長しちゃいますよ
気にしないんだから いやいやと言ったってもね
まあそれで まあまあ気にするよりは気にしない方がいいかもしれませんだけど
その分苦しくないんで
やっぱりそれを知ってほしいんですよ
あ こういうことで まあこれはもう植物と同じ
どんどんどんどん成長するものではないかと
で それ知った方が それはなんとか治療してなくすということはできるんですね
ですから この鈍感でいくということは
そういうわけでないんですね
だから鈍感ということは
この危険なものは気にしない
無視するということだからね
やっぱり敏感な方がいいんですね
敏感になってくると いきなり今まで気にしなかったものまで気にしちゃいますから
かなりもうショック受けちゃいますよ
だって私の話に乗っちゃうと
生協で売ってる野菜でも気楽に買えなくなっちゃいますからね
だからどうしようかということになるでしょうね
ですから このまあ  そういうふうな
ちょっとした壁っていうのはね
ありますけど やっぱりすごい敏感になる
鋭敏になる なって心を見ると
たとえゴキブリが 1匹部屋に入っても
誰もいない部屋 自分だけいる部屋に
自分の心はかなり動揺して
それに合わせて思考パターンと人格まで変わってしまう
それでゴキブリが出て行ったところで
やっと落ち着こうと思うと
そこで蛾が入ったりしますね
そうすると またそれに合わせてまた心思考パターンが概念現象が変わってしまってね
蛾という現象が 蛾がいるんだという現象が心に入っちゃうんです
それでまたもう心がもう揺らいで傷んでしまうんですね
痛くなっちゃうんです
苦しくなっちゃうんですね
それで安らぎを体験する方法として
この これは単なる思考の問題だと
現象概念の問題だと これ実際っていうのは別にどうったことはないと
世の中っていうのはね
人が生まれると 人々は死ぬのは当たり前
そんな気にすることじゃないんですよ
でも自分の親が死んじゃうとえらく落ち込んだりする
自分の子供なんか死んじゃうとものすごいもう大変ですね
でももう毎日のようにもうすごい子供が死んでいくんだけど
それ全然ね まあ気にしない
ですから 子同士のことを大変悲しいことやとかね
そんな話も一つの概念であって
どうってことはない と
みんなもう死んでいく
赤ちゃんも死んでいく
子供も死んでいく 鳥もいろんな
いつでも死んでいくことであって
自分でもそうやって死んでしまうでしょう
だからこの概念に引っかかっちゃうと
そう簡単にうまくはいかない
だから もうこの今日はいい天気で歩いてきたんだからね
その時も駅から上がって
またもう考えるものがなくて
何を考えようかなと思ったところへ
私はもうある人の質問があって
この死んだ人について考えたんですね
で どうするんでしょうかとも
人が死んじゃったら それで私は正直なところ考えるんですね
我々の仏教から見れば
それで人は死んじゃったら
それは燃やしちゃえばいいんじゃないかと
それは正直なところなんですね
燃やして骨と捨てちゃえばいいでしょうね
捨てるとこだったら 植木鉢にでもね
入れなさいよと 肥料になるんだから
それが正しい答えなのに
なんでこれできないかと
なんでそれは人に正直に言えないかと
それで私たちの場合は
やっぱり人が死んじゃったら当然お寺に来るでしょうし
で 来たらその人の家に行って
葬式のぐちゃぐちゃな儀式とかいろんなことをやらなくちゃいけないし
だから  これ燃やせよと言っちゃうと
それ一言葉だけでも大変なことになっちゃうんですね
火葬とか何とかしなくちゃいけない
言わなくちゃいけないんですね
だったらなんで生ゴミを火葬すると言わないんですかね
ゴミ処理場をなんで火葬場と言わないんでしょうかね
なんで火葬場にゴミ処理場よと言わないんでしょうかね
だからそれは正直にその人にとっては
自分の親が死んだとかね
母が死んだ 父が死んだと
だからこれどうしましょうかということ
もう向こうだったらもうもう日本ほど派手じゃないんだけど
やっぱりこの遺体をね
何時何分に家の中から持ち上げるかとかね
外へ出すかとか いろいろいろいろ決まりまたある
頭は何向きにするかとかね
向こうは西ですね 西向
頭は西の方にして置く
で あの人住んでるんだからではなくてね
まあ東は幸福の方で 西は不幸な方やと
向こうの方向でそう考えてるだけのことですけどね
阿弥陀さんが西にいるんだからっていう話じゃないんだから
西 西 一体どこ行ったってどこかわからないんだから
西っていうのはね 中国人にとってはインドなんかはね
まあブッダの世界は西だからいいんですけどね
私たちから見れば北なんですけどね
そうすると で 中央インドの人々はどこですかと
遺体は立たせおくんですかね
ブッダはそちらに生まれていたんだからといって
ということにもなるし
また阿弥陀様がね 西にいるんだから
どこ行ったって西っていうのはないでしょうに
どこが西かと 西を向かって歩くと
どんどんどんどん自分いたところに戻ってくるんだから
とにかくもういろいろ赤誰儀式人間が作るですから
遺体の頭をどちらの方向へ置いておくかもいろいろ考えちゃうと
だから私たちは お寺の場合はどちらへもよくうまく収まりますからね
ここの方が収まりますね
そしたらそれだけ 西どこか全然もう
で 自分のお寺の場合は
これはうまくお寺の構成によってね
お釈迦様とか本堂とかあるところは
お坊さんたち住んでるところから見れば西なんですね
だから じゃあやっぱり仏の方
お釈迦様の方に頭を入れて
それは当たり前だから
それで西でもあるしね
大丈夫です でも私のもう一番上の長老が亡くなったときでは
もう西かな 覚えてないんですけどね
その場でその方向 じゃあこっちはこういう形でいいんでしょうという
簡単な単純に決めますけど
それが正しいんですけど
人間はそううまくいかないんですね
それで自分の父は死んじゃったんだから
母親死んじゃったんだから
じゃあこの骨 この灰はどうしましょうかとかね
もう大事に何かどこかへ持っていって
どこかに保管してもらうとか
お寺で保管してもらうとか
いろんなことを考えちゃう
それでそれぐらいその人の死んだ人の骨やら灰やらね
大事にする人に 他の人の遺体やらね
灰やら骨やらあげたらどうなりますかと
その場合は平気でゴミ扱いでしょ
そんなものを埋めておけとか捨てなさいよとかね
だから他人の遺体だったら全くゴミ扱いで
自分の母親たちや親戚の子供の遺体だけはもう仏様扱いでというね
それ自体ももう屁理屈もいいところなんですね
だから遺灰とか何とかってとかね
家に持っていて大事に線香立てるんだったら
自分の誰か死ぬまで待たないで
もう誰かが死んじゃったら
そこら辺のね ホームレスの方や誰か
その人の遺灰を持ってきて
自分の家でちゃんと安置して線香を立てればいいでしょうに
それはしません それはすごい不幸
ものすごい気持ち悪いとかね
とんでもないよと 何するんでかと
そこまで怒られたりする
でもやっぱり自分のものになってくるとまた違うと
だからこの そうやってこの人間っていうのは
もうこの思考と概念というものに引っかかって
かなり苦しんだりする
だから事実っていうのはなかなか残酷に聞こえるかもしれませんですけどね
だから そういう風に有の概念っていうのは
派手に人を苦しませるんですよ
人の骨と言っちゃうと
ものすごく汚いし 嫌でしょうし
気持ち悪いと錯覚するし
もういろいろそんなものあると
もう化けが出てくるんではないかとかと
でも自分の親の骨だったら
まあそんなものではなくなっちゃうんですね
同じ物質ですけども だからそれに誰かがしつらな一言葉でも言うとね
大変な結果になってしまっちゃうしね
人もものすごく自分のことを侮辱したんだよとかね
そう思ったりもするしね
だからそこでどちらが正しいという話ではなくて
人間の苦しみの話なんですよ
だから人間がそれで苦しむんだよと
それで次に行きます イティ ヤンヒ コータッタ ネホーティ テーナ タン スンニャン サマヌパッサティ
このようにヤンヒ コータッタ ネホーティ
そちらにもう何か無いものあるでしょう
タッタ そちらにおいてヤンヒ ネホーティ
何か何か無いものがありますね
テーナ そのものについてタン スンニャン サマヌパッサティ
スンニャン 空であると認識する
観察する そのスンニャという空という現象ですね
それはその現象を受け取る
ヤンパナタットアビスアッタンホーティ
アビスアッタン なくなってないもの
まだまだなくなって消えてないものがあるんだったら
タンサンタンイダンアッティーティパジャナーティ
それについては あ これがあると
シューニャの反対はアッティウということなんですね
それがあると その人は知りますと
エワンピスエサーアーナンダヤターブッチャアビパッラッタパリシッダシュンヤターヴァッカンティバヴァンティ
エワン このようですよと
アーナンダ これこの方法ですよと
ヤターブッチャ ありのままっていうこと
アビパッラッタ 心はこの
なんて言いますか へんてこりんなこと思考になってない
と 日本訳はどんな言葉を使っていますかね
アーナンダにこのようにして
彼にこの如実  不転倒ですね
この転倒っていうのをこの逆さまにものごと見るということなんですね
だからこの まあ逆さまでしょうしね
自分のご先祖のお墓だったらもうすごい尊敬するし
でも人の墓っていうのはえらい嫌いし
お墓見えるところ 家でも建てたくないと
買って墓でしたと言えば
もうその その土地も買わないとかね
という人々が自分の戦争のために
まあ墓作っても その大変でしょうね
こんな何やと お墓っていうのは不幸でもう危険というかね
嫌なところだったら もう嫌だったら作るなよと
お墓は怖・おびえるかと
一般的にはね で 自分の戦争のためにお墓を作ってるのは
だからそれ同じですから
そうすると おびえるところで怖いところになっちゃいますけどね
だからそういう思考っていうのを転倒と呼ぶんですね
逆さまっていう風に で
とにかく一般の人々の思考っていうのは
転倒で逆さまであると
だから まあこの逆さまではなくて
如実に ありのまま ものすごい単純に見てください
そうすると パリシッダ
すごい清らかな シュンヤターヴァッカン
すごい清らかなこの という清浄たる
この空という概念 空性という
この まあシュンヤタ 空ということは
正気が現れる  正気ってちょっとおかしい訳なんですけど
まあシュンヤタという
この感覚 気持ち  生まれてくる
出てくるんですね 空性の正気ですね
空性の正気ですから まあいいですね
空性の気持ちが生まれてくる
空性の気持ちが生まれてくるっていうことは
かなり気楽で ストレスはひとかけらもなく穏やかでいられるっていうことなんです
だから有は危険なんですよ
有に反対する無は仏教は認めませんから
あの 空ですね 空っていうのは有に対する無ではないんです
やっぱり龍樹は哲学的にはお釈迦様の教えはね
まあ論理はね 捕まっていたんだから
これはあの 何何かにパティッチャということって
何何かにこの立場で見るということなんですね
だからこの うん 当てはめてしようかね
パティッチャっていうのは
まあインド語でその「より」というかね
何々に寄り よ まあ寄りかかって
あるいは何かの角度で見るとっていうことで
だからあのミガラマートゥという庄屋を
だからこれかなり高価な建物でしたし
お城みたいな感じの かなり今も跡がありますからね
もうちょっとのお寺ではなかったんですよ
だからこれぐらいものだったら
まあ必ずゾウ何頭かいるし
馬がいっぱいいるし 馬車があるし
牛がいるし 人々がいて
店があって 大騒ぎでしょうしね
だからその立場から見ると何もないんだという
だからそうやってこの空っていうのは
そうやってこの相対的に成り立つものなんですね
だからそれは龍樹がいとも簡単に長いと言えばあるかと思っているかと
それを短いということはと思う
あなた思っているんだから
長いっていうことは何意味があるんだよと
だから短いという言葉が消えちゃうと
長いっていうものもなくなるんだから
長いっていうのは依存して存在する
短いっていうものも依存して存在は相対的なことで
一時的に存在するようなものであって
実際は存在しないという論理なんですね
背が高い あの あの人は背が高いと言った途端
そうでない人のこと もう頭に入ってるんですね
だから全ての言葉はそうやってこの現象であって
何かにもう相対的に依存しているんですよ
インディペンデンではない
独立した言葉はないんですね
概念はないという帰結
論理ですね 龍樹持っていくの
だからその種はあるんですよ
この中でも そこでもある角度で考えると空であって
ある角度で考えると有だよと
だから空き地に行って村
人々とか街とか商店街とか考えちゃうと
なんと楽かと これ空やと
ないんだからっていうと
でも空き地ですから 空き地やと思ってると有になっちゃうんですね
有になった瞬間にもう苦しみが出てくる
だから実際に空という徹底的な形而上学的な概念うんぬんではないんですよ
ただその だからその見方が
まあ龍樹はちゃんと取ってるんですよ
お釈迦様のこの論理的というかね
このポイントをね この相対的に
でもお釈迦様はこの それは相対性の
相対性論を語るためではなくて
心を清らかにする方法として実践としてしか語らないんですね
そこで空性の一番わかりやすいところ
まあそれぐらいの空性で気楽にいることは我々にもできます
それからまあもっともっと厳密に
あの まあ進んでいきますけどね
経典は まあ涅槃まで行きますけどね
で 涅槃まで行きますけど
すっごいこの単純な論理でまず理解していただくんですよ
家にいろんな品物たくさんある場合はね
まあ使うこともしないし
もう粗大ゴミもいろいろあるし
もうすぐ捨てることもできないしとかね
まあ困って困ってとかね
で あるものだからそれなりに手入れもしなくちゃいけないしね
それで ある後でいろいろ話をやったりして
とにかく粗大ゴミとして全部処分しましょうと
そこまで有の世界だからもう苦しいんですね
電話かけて予約して もうその粗大ゴミを処理業者やらいろいろあるんだから
そちらに頼んで いつ来るんでしょうかと
まあ今週はダメですよ
来週ですよと言っちゃうと
また来週まで待たなくちゃいけないし
また思い出してあげなきゃ
いろいろ苦しいことはいっぱいあるんですけど
まあとにかく決まった日で
この粗大ゴミ扱う業者というか
なんとか来て どちらでしょうか
それで全部もう出しちゃいますね
だいぶ自分の玄関からあのトラックに乗せた瞬間で
自分が戻ってくる瞬間で
あ そういうものはもうないということで
すぐほっとするんですね
とします で あの そういうふうな感じで
このストレスが消え 消えるんですよ
だからストレスを消すためには
このもう空性しか方法ないんです
で なんで仕事でストレス溜まっちゃうと
あの飲み屋とかね あるいは踊りディスコに行って踊ったりして発散しましたと
その場合もディスコに行ってむちゃくちゃ酒飲んで
もうむちゃくちゃ遊ぶと
頭から仕事を 会社という概念は消えちゃうんですよ
あの消える その空性も存在しない
その人にはどうすればかっこよく踊れるかとかね
誰と組んで踊るかとかね
まあそれしか頭の中にないんだからね
それでストレス発散しましたよと
と思っちゃいますけど
でも完全たる発散ではなくて
それで踊りということは有の世界だからね
飲み屋さんだったら飲み屋さんというのは有の世界でしょうし
ディスコテークも有の世界でしょうし
そちらにはそれなりのストレスと苦しみはまあ入っちゃうんですね
だから世の中ではそうやって置き換えの方法でストレスを消して消していくんですね
今のストレスは別なストレスで置き換えちゃう
それはストレスと思ったら
また別なストレスで置き換える
例えば毎日ディスコと言えば
これ死にもう死んだ方がマシぐらい苦しいんですよ
毎日ディスコに行って遊びましょうと言っちゃうと
これ楽しいやと それは成り立ちません
それで 1週間一回ぐらい遊んで
それでまあ その苦しみが仕事に行くことで消しちゃいます
仕事に行ったらまた別のストレス溜まるんだから
それでまた飲み屋さんに行って
そのストレスで置き換えて
なくなったと思っちゃいますけど
ずっと置き換えだけなんですね
だからこちらでもそのポイントといえばその同じポイントなんですけど
まあ置き換えるといったっていうのでも
こちらはちゃんとなかった
あれはもうないというところにまあピンポイントしたいんですね
心を集中して欲しいんですね
あ 終わったと もうゴミを処理しましたと
もうきれいさっぱりやと
もうないんだと それで有の世界に入ると
人間っていうのはどうしてもとんでもないことをします
例えばこの新しい家を借りたりしますね
何一つもない ああ この家広々していいなと瞬間思っちゃいますけど
自分の家から来ているんだからね
それで一旦来たら こちらにやっぱりソファ一つあればねとかね
こちらにもうちょっと何とかあればとかね
こちらにこういうものはこちらに何か置いたら
それでまたもう半年経つとまた人に住むところなくなっちゃうんですね
狭いとかね あれは有の論理で
だからあの思考は苦しみで世界はその有の思考できてるんです
だからまあ苦しみの世界というんですね
とにかく何か作るというね
それではストレスは消えません
苦しみも消えません ですから
空性の思考に入りません
入らないと うまくいかないんですよ
だからこの出家したの
そういうわけには全部捨ててみなさいよ
社会まで 社会の一員としてそこまで捨てなさい
名前まで捨ててみなさいと
だから出家すると名前まで捨てる
まあお坊さんのお坊さんの場合はもう全部もう全部登録から法律からもうもう削除ですよ
まあそういう人は存在しないっていうぐらいのことで
まあまあ そこまでちょっと問題もありますから
やっぱり出家してからいろいろ犯罪起こしたりしちゃうと困っちゃいますからね
まあ後からまたまた法律を出すかようになったりもしますけどね
我々の場合はやっぱり登録消します
登録は消しますけど 漱石というまた新しい登録に
結局政府は同じ法律で扱っちゃうんですね
日本で流行ってる戒名戒名の起源もそちらにあるんですね
一旦仏道に入ったら いわゆる出家したらもう家の姓は捨てる
まあ名前よりも必ず姓は捨てるんですね
姓は捨てる まあ大体パーリ語を使って使ってますから
出家はね あの だからパーリ語もなかなか排他的な言語で
あのなんだかんだで入れません
もうすごい排他的なんでパーリ語自体は
変な思考やら変なこと変なではないんですけど
この異質のね 言葉やらとかなかなか入りにくいんですね
ブッダの思考の概念だけに限っているような感じなんですね
だからサンスクリットとはちょっと性質はもうちょっとのところじゃないんですね
結構違いますね  そういうことだから
このいろんなこのエイブラハムとかね
もう仏とかね そんな名前で入ってきたら
このもうパーリ語の中でも受け入れられません
だからもう全部捨てちゃえと名前も
捨てたところでダンマヴィハーリとかね
そういう仏教的な何か名前を入れちゃうんですね
ウパーリとかね もうなんだとか
アーナンダとかね それでいろいろお坊さんたちのいろんなこの法事とか儀式とかありますから
その場合はまあ人の名前使う使うんだから文章の中に入れますからね
文章の中に簡単に入れられると
まあそういうことで とにかく全て捨てたんだという意味で名前を入れるんですね
まあそれはいろいろ変わって変わって
日本になってきて 戒名という言葉の意味はそんなに変わってはないんですけど
使い方はまるっきりもう仏教的ではないんですね
遺体に戒名をあげる坊主も
本当にもう大乗坊主とも言えないんですよ
大乗の坊さんたちも昔はね
かなりもう真剣 真面目でしたけどね
アホなことをしなかったんですけどもね
遺体ってのはもう捨てなさいと
燃やしちゃえばいいでしょうしね
それに名前あげたりね
戒名 っていう まあそれはまあこちらのね
まあ考え方で 何の意味もないんですね
だからこの戒名 名前なんか中国人が好きなんですね
だからこのテーラワーダの世界でもね
なんとか仏教の名前欲しい欲しいやとね
言うんですよ 西洋人もよく口出しちゃいますね
その場合は はいはい 分かりました
誰にでもささっと名前をあげちゃいます
全然真剣なことでもないんです
一応仏教に関わるあるだけで
まあまあ仏教に興味があって
見えたり やっぱりせっかくだから仏教的な名前欲しいやと言ったら
はい 分かりました よくよく洗うからこの名前ですよと
だからシンガポールやらね
マレーシアの中国の人々というのはみんな名前持ってます
仏教の名前 お寺に来るとその名前でまあ呼んでますね
我々にとっても中国人の名前っていうのは覚えにくいしね
だってみんな同じね リーとかね
リとかね なんかみんな同じ
4つ5つぐらいの発音でもう全部だからそれちょっと覚えにくいしね
リさんと百人いるんで
どちらのリかと またね
もう それでもう便利だから
お坊さんたちに勝ってみんなに仏教の名前を
中国の人々もこれある一つの遊びでもありますから
お互いにでもその名前で呼び合ったりして
そこをすごく気持ちよく楽しく
で 喜んでいるんですね
そんな真剣なことでもないんです
だからもう年賀状やらそういう時にやら
そういう新しくもう仏教からね
もらった名前で来る時も楽しいし
自分もすごくその名前で格好の中で自分の本物の名前書くとかね
で まあ元はリーでしたけど
今はもうクサラーとかなんて
そうやってもうまあ遊んでますよ
だからまあ楽しい世界ですからね
仏教っていうのはね すごい
この あんなにこのクソ真面目っていうこともないし
余計な概念にはめられて真剣になって
また新しい苦しみを作るっていうことでもないんです
もう気持ちよく楽しく
で 時々お坊さんたちにすごい発音しにくくて
人の名前覚えにくくなると
向こう側からこれめんどくさいんだから
私に覚えやすい仏教の名前くれと
そうすると坊さんたちも自分たちの呼びやすい覚えやすい名前をつけちゃうと
ね まあそこでお互いすごい楽しくなるということになるんですね
まあそういう風にまあなってるんで
出家してたらもうこれも決まりで名前変えます
大体姓は必ず変えますし
名前ももう９０パーセントは消えて消しちゃいますし
で 在家の母親がつけた名前も仏教的な名前で
いろいろいい名前だったらまあ使う場合もありますけど
ちょっと変えて使うんでそのまま使いません
そこでこの有の世界と空勝の世界っていう
この心理学的なそういう働きで
心が苦しみが生まれる
一つから一つからは苦しみが消えちゃってリラックスできるんだというところで終了いたします
で それからはもうちょっと次に結構仏教的な世界に入ります
入っても論理は この論理を覚えておいてください
この同じ論理でいくんです
解脱まで行きますけど
その経典は 論理は同じです
[紙の音]